[Music]
Wendy's in Colorado is it better to bank
or the local credit union a state credit
union a local bank or a national bank
most banks are national banks
technically they participate in the
Federal Reserve the FDIC insurance
applies most credit unions are insured
by the NCUA which is the equivalent for
credit unions of the FDIC and so most
financial institutions that you deal
with nowadays that 90 some odd percent
of them I don't worry about their
financial solvency as a matter of
whether you bank with them or not now I
don't deal with the large mega banks
under any circumstances and I actually
don't understand why anybody does why
you would get treated the way you get
treated at Wells Fargo or Bank of
America and thence keep doing business
there's beyond me because if you want to
find incompetence and by the bushel
basket you can find it around places
like that it's horrendous I mean there's
dumb as those airlines who are dragging
people off their airplanes you know it's
just the customer does not matter people
don't matter to them you're a number so
I have chosen to do business only with
regional banks where I can have solid
connectivity with relationships and or
smaller local banks and or credit unions
there are a few credit unions but very
few that are very very large and kind of
lost their soul the 99% of credit unions
out there are very customer oriented
they're like a very very small town bank
in most cases but if you can get a local
bank you're just going to get treated
better in this day and time with the
internet and the way they package their
services you're gonna get the same level
of you know Web Access web
sophistication for dealing with you know
your checking account moving money from
savings to checking and balancing your
reconciling your checking account we
used to call it balancing your checking
account online all of that you can do it
all just about everybody's got all that
now I mean if you find somebody this
substandard on that then
do business with them but but you know
it's just really even the smallest of
the small pretty much has a
cut-and-paste thing they put together in
there that they bought from somebody but
the bottom line is the service to you is
just fine just fine you've got access to
multiple ATMs you got access to you know
everything out there and what you're
looking for is relationship and you may
get some better fees here or there
credit unions by and large will have
better deals on checking and a few
little odds and it may be a little bit
better interest rate on your savings or
something like that
but not always but most of the time so
just check all of that and that's what
you're looking for but I'm not gonna
take a quarter of a point on my savings
account and then be dealing with
freaking Wells Fargo
no thank you there's not enough money on
the planet to get me to go in that place
again no thank you
I mean they have fired almost ten
thousand people now for creating
accounts fraudulently for people just to
meet sales goals when you fire ten
thousand people for fraud and you're a
bank hello I mean really I mean you deal
with somebody like Wells Fargo it's just
silly
Bank of America the way they treat
people Fifth Third the way they treat
people son trusts the way they treat
people I mean just look at these large
banks and look at it no thank you
I don't anything to do with that stuff
no I'm not calling for a boycott I'm
just calling I'm just telling you look
why do you do business with people that
give you a lousy service and you don't
and mistreat you that's just silly don't
do it
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
now
[Applause]
[Music]